foreign
what time is it oh I've been waiting for
this it's time for TK's tweet of the
week
TK what do you got for us today
this comes from Billy chapata at I am
b-r-i
-l-l-y-a-n-t all right here we go TK's
tweet of the week courtesy of Billy
chapata sometimes the emptiness you feel
is just your spirit telling you to come
back home to yourself
telling you to commit more time to you
telling you to find Melodies that your
heart enjoys beating to again
telling you to stop leaving love for
yourself
unattended we've been talking a lot
about emptiness recently on this podcast
and trying to reframe give some
perspective here and I like this is
additional perspective because quite
often the emptiness that we experience
is not a bad thing we've been sold a
meme that says
we need to fill the void yeah you're
feeling empty but of course empty isn't
a bad thing in fact you look at the room
here around us it's relatively empty
it's not completely empty it has
everything that we need we're not going
without and I think what happens quite
often is we confuse that open space with
going without what happens when you buy
a 4 000 square foot home
you feel compelled to fill every corner
every nook every cranny with stuff
nothing wrong with the things but
anytime we're buying something just to
fill an empty space
it's actually saying something about
what's going on inside us I feel
incomplete and this incomplete home is
merely an extension of my own
incompleteness no you are complete in an
empty room in an empty home and you can
fill the space with things that enhance
your life that magnify your life that
amplify your life then add value to your
life
but if you're compelled just because an
Advertiser or a peer or Society
told you that you have an empty house
and you got to fill up the stuff
well you're going to keep feeling empty
the stuff will merely widen the void now
yeah that clutter
the void is filled with excess stuff
excess books excess relationships excess
obligations excess things in our lives
that don't complete us if anything they
incomplete us let's go back to the Tweet
itself will you read the first line one
more time sometimes the emptiness you
feel is just your spirit telling you to
come back home to yourself
um isn't it interesting like that empty
feeling I think everyone gets it at a
certain point and it's so hard to for me
to decide whether or not it's a
legitimate empty feeling or
um if if it's uh something that I need
to embrace so what I mean by the legit
legitimacy of it is is there something
that I'm missing in my life right now so
when I start to feel empty like that I
look at
um I look at my values and I'm like okay
what do I value you know here are the
foundational values that I have and I
kind of look at each one and I'm like
how am I doing in these areas and you
know you can kind of look at them like
uh you know buckets of sand or water and
like the least empty bucket that might
be something that I want to focus on but
sometimes I look at those areas and I'm
like no I'm doing pretty good on these
like I don't know why I got this empty
feeling and that you know after looking
at those foundational values I can give
myself permission to kind of just
Embrace The Emptiness I've been reading
a lot about
um
uh the Sedona Method recently and man
like that is such a powerful book on
helping you Embrace and even let go of
some of these emotions and Emptiness is
one of those like it's it's it's again
like sometimes it's legitimate and you
gotta look at something other times
you're just having a little empty
feeling and that's okay like I like to
make friends with the void when I can
you know I think the void is
only avoid when we've actually done
something in our own lives to create the
void hmm I I don't know that it exists
outside of that what I mean by that is
you'll feel empty if you have a ton of
debt and it's really
pressuring you right because now you're
Tethered to a lifestyle that creates a
particular emptiness right or when I was
obese there was an emptiness there like
I felt devoid of health health is the
default State Health is simply an
absence of disease or dysfunction right
and so
the default state is not empty and I
think that applies to all the areas in
our lives the house is not empty either
right it is spacious and then I can fill
it with things that merely add value to
my house to my home to my friends to my
community
it's interesting when you say that we
can't achieve fulfillment by filling our
house with things
and I would say and that's also true
with respect to emptying our house of
things you can have an empty home
and An Empty Soul because as we often
say minimalism isn't about the absence
of things but about the presence of
meaning and intentionality in our
engagement with all things and so
sometimes in our efforts to please
others and our efforts to acquire
fulfillment we give away our time or we
give away our stuff but because we are
giving without intentionality we also
give away our boundaries and when we
give away our boundaries we give away
our health we give away our sanity and
that underlying sensation of emptiness
is the Soul's way of whispering to us
please come back
in your effort to get people to like you
you have lost the very essence of you
and there is no longer a me that even
gets to enjoy the experience when other
people like me what good is it to be
liked when you aren't even there to
appreciate the experience of being like
because you gave away your essence you
gave away your authenticity you gave
away your health and your sanity and
that's what I love about brother Billy's
tweet he's telling us don't run from
that emptiness don't condemn yourself
for that for that emptiness don't avoid
it listen to it let it teach you let it
call you back home to yourself and to
your health and to your Wellness to your
self-care did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free